[Music]
you shot an episode of Modern Family in
Australia yes I did want to bring home
the sand like souvenirs for the kids and
stuff so we went I went to the market
and they trade in kangaroo balls what
yeah that's right
they sell kangaroo Bakar balls and
there's a very very brisk trade in the
kangaroo ball today you get a lighter or
a fun explain you can't just say
kangaroo balls and move on like that
we're all with you they remove the balls
of a cat the testicles of a kangaroo and
then they're stuffed with something as
it was I is it like furry dice there's
bit yes they're like furry dice and when
they're very furry it was kind of funny
although they're very hard it's as if
like imagine your lover
it has rigor mortis and you're waking up
in the morning they're dead okay your
male lover now let's go back to how did
we get you I'm with I'm having I'm with
a dead man and I'm feeling around down
there is the worst conversational train
I've ever been on
imagine you're in my bed with a man who
may be dead first thing you do check his
balls when there's not a lot of hair on
the balls anyone tuning in right now
I'll check out Conan just for a second I
don't like him alive
watch it and then you biggest cheer that
one set there's not a lot of hair on the
balls
they are kind of humanoid ax and that's
it wasn't right that just wasn't right
it really yeah I probably should never
have repeated any of this
you're talking about the scrotum this is
not balls this is a scrotum and a
scrotum the scrotum is yeah the thing
that encloses and then the balls of the
actual organ is yes yes this is the
whole package oh there's so there are
any would you
are there the these are actually in
there this kind of a thing it's kind of
more of like a heart shape the camera
behind about things like you take that
picture to your job I have to fix this I
have to fix this for Turner so that we
don't have a problem there we go it's a
happy guy now
[Applause]
it's it's professor scrotes I'm sorry I
blew it I just fixed this whole thing on
PBS and now it's professor scrotes yeah
hold up in light bulb